hi everyone welcome back to Art of the
part
I'm out in the shop today and I wanted
to talk through some of my procedures in
second operation and I thought this
might be helpful to make a video on for
the students so right now I'm working on
the
98432 part and I just finished one of
the components and I wanted to go ahead
and unload it and load in a new
component and measure the first one to
see if I have to make any adjustments to
my work offset so the program is
finished running I'm going to go ahead
and unlock the door
you can see you hear that that unlocked
I'm going to pull the door open
and you want to make sure that you have
your safety glasses on because you don't
want coolants or chips to be blowing
back in your face so right now I'm going
to go ahead and blow off my coolant
blow off any chips
okay
and the part is secure right now on the
Vise I have to release it it's also good
to check that my parallels didn't move
so that's good so I'm going to go ahead
and grab my torque wrench
and then turn it to release
over here and then I'm going to pop this
out
and we're just going to take a quick
look here normally I would blow this off
with two hands but we'll kind of make do
here
all right so we have the part here I'm
going to grab a towel really quick
wipe this off get any coolant or grease
off of it
and we can see that we finished up
second operation
apologies there
we see we have machine block two we have
the part number 98432 you can see that
here on our blueprint and when we finish
second operation we left these little
Burrs in these two locations for the
holes
and I don't want to go ahead and make a
third operation
and clean these up or add a chamfer so
what I ended up doing was modified a
little drill Point here to go ahead and
drill these two locations so I don't
have to set this up back in the machine
again so that'll remove the Burr
[Music]
okay
I'll fill it with my hand I can still
see uh feel the high point on this one
so I'll go ahead and run it again
okay
so that feels pretty good I can see here
on the blueprint that I have a z
dimension of seven or sorry 0.725 so I
wanted to check that here on my height
gauge
see that it's here at zero I can kind of
pull this back and zero it out again
just in case but I'll lift my gauge up
then I'll put my part underneath it
and touch off I see that I'm at 0.725
and then like half a ten
go ahead and measure the other side here
so I'm actually getting 0.726 which
tells me that I have to make an
adjustment in my work offset I'm still
with intolerance because I'm plus or
minus three thousands here so I'm well
within the part acceptance however I
just want to be a little bit more
accurate so what I'm going to do on the
next component is actually just lower my
offset by let's just say half a tenth
kind of see where that ends up split the
difference I also printed out these part
holders which are pretty nice so that
the parts don't scratch on top of each
other
this is a completed first operation and
I'm going to go ahead and load this in
the machine and run second operation so
it gets completed like the other part
so what I would do is take this and I
try to orientate my parts so that when I
ever whenever I have the lettering or
the numbering all I want to do is I want
to flip it like this
not like this
so I'm just flipping the part over and I
have a work stop set up here so that I
don't have to touch off my XYZ zeros
every single time and I'll just put this
into place normally I would do this with
two hands and then I would tighten this
while holding it against the workshop
and also holding it down but I just got
one hand here and I've set my torque
wrench up to 75 newton meters so I heard
a click it means I'm in good spot
however my parallels are still loose
beneath so what I'm gonna have to do
here
is actually hit it with a dead blow
hammer
I kind of treat this almost like
changing a tire you're not trying to do
one side or all in a row so I'm gonna go
in alternating Corners so I'll go one
two three four and then the fifth in the
middle so we'll go one two three four
fifth in the middle and that should hit
my parallels down into the Vise so that
this is perfectly flat I can go ahead
and continue with second operation
so now that the part is secure I'm going
to go ahead and close the door
and if we're imagining that this is the
first part that we're running for the
day I would go ahead
lock the door here
and I would go into my program manager
find whatever program make sure it's
matching the blueprint and I would go
ahead and look at the part
scroll down here make sure that I got
the correct work piece good and I'm
going to go ahead and simulate this
and simulate it out to see if what I am
Machining matches the blueprint this is
just a 3D graphic I'm not going to be
able to pull any Dimensions or anything
but it gives me a good idea of what the
program is going to look like
while it's running I'm also going to go
ahead and grab my blueprint here
and we can see
that that's pretty close
that's exactly what we want
so I'm going to say that that blueprint
or sorry that um
program matches the blueprint we can go
ahead and run this
so I'll go ahead and click on execute
load this into the machine now since I
already have my work offsets already set
up I'm going to go ahead and change my
work offset and I was a little too tall
so I'm going to subtract that from my
current Z location so I'm going to go
down here into offsets
this is my g43 or sorry G 543 work
offset I'm going to go to my Z value and
I'm just going to go ahead and minus so
I'm just typing this down here minus
.001
sorry I think I was going to go half a
tenth so 0.00
so we're taking off a half a tenth we're
splitting the difference there because
we measured 0.6 or sorry
0.726 on one side and 0.725 and 5 on the
other side so I just took off half a
tenth there
and then I'll jump back here into our
machine so I'm jumping back here into
the machine page and then looks like I
got the correct program number up there
at the header we should be good to go
let's pretend that I looked through all
my tools and they match the tools that
are here inside of my offset page or my
tool list everything seems to match
and I can go ahead and let this part run
so I'm going to go back here to machine
get back here in the machine and then
I'll scroll all the way up
and then I'll go ahead and hit cycle
start but again if we're just running
this for the first time today I've
already been running a couple parts but
I would start my program with both my
pots so my rapid and my linear feed
rates all the way off so I'll hit cycle
start
and we'll see that I get a warning here
it's telling me that it needs some kind
of feed so I'm going to turn on my rapid
so that we can cycle the tool change
so again this is our rapid here on the
top
recycling out a tool
and I'm going to just turn off my Rapids
so that the tool doesn't accidentally
gouge the work piece or the work holding
and I'm going to ease this in and I'm
also going to turn off my coolant to see
if I make solid contact with the Z zero
that I established for my work offset so
I'm going to turn off my coolant there
and I'm going to go ahead and slowly
turn up my rapid so that I can see
my tool approached the part I'll slow it
down as we get closer and closer and
closer so this is g00
so I'm controlling it with my rapid
right now
and I'm about to reach the end of the
rapid command in my program
so my distances go is zero I don't have
anywhere else to go now I'm getting
another warning it's asking for another
feed even though I'm turning up my rapid
it's not changing the color of the
warning there so I might as well turn
off my rapid and I'm going to start
playing around with my linear feed rate
and this is why it's important for us to
turn off that coolant because I wanted
to see if I make contact when I turn on
my linear feed so we'll go ahead and
turn on our linear feed
we're starting to move we can also see
that the
light has turned green I can hear that
we've made contact
seems like we're pretty good I'll go
ahead and pass through here
go ahead and turn off my linear
and seems like we made pretty good
contact
so it's going to move into the next pass
I'm pretty happy with that so I can go
ahead and probably turn on my coolants
let that run out
[Music]
okay so right now
my rapid is turned on but my linear is
turned off so as it reaches the end of
this block we can see that the color has
changed back to that orange it's telling
us that it needs another feed no matter
what I do the linear here it's not going
to move we can see here on our program
that it's calling out for g00 so I'm
going to turn this all the way down
and I'm going to allow the tool to
retract out now
so I'm going to turn on my rapid
you can see that the colors change green
and now we're cycling the tool change
you can also see our mo6 changing to
that end Mill
and again good habit to let the tool
change but then as soon as the tool
changes turn down your
rapid feed rate so that we can control
how this approaches so once again we'll
go ahead and turn off our coolant
we'll turn on our rapid so I'm going to
ease my rapid in
seems like the coolant turned back on
for that specific line of code so I'm
going to turn that off
and then I'm going to again turn my
wrap it up
and ease it into the part
now
it's at a pretty good position
[Music]
it's going to continue moving down go
ahead and feed that down
can't go anywhere else
I'll turn my rapid off
it's asking me for g01 linear feed rate
right here
and what I would normally do is I would
ease this in and then stop the program
and then measure out with a scale
so that I could see if the tool in this
instance would hit on the Vise so I'm
going to go ahead and do that I'm going
to turn this up
slowly but as it approaches the part and
right before it makes a cut
so it's just easing in right now
I'm going to stop it
[Music]
and then I'm actually going to stop my
program
so I stopped the tool stop the program I
interrupted it it hasn't canceled the
program but at this point it allows me
to go ahead and unlock the door so
unlock the door
[Music]
and as I said I would normally
take a scale
and check to see if a scale can fit
beneath the
tip of the tool and then the top of my
Vise so we actually can see that there
is space between this so as I run this
path I feel safe in knowing that there's
at least some gap between the tip of the
tool and then the top of the Vise so
just a quick check there we can also do
the math for our distance to go but
I'm more of a visual guy we'll go ahead
and close this out
I'm gonna go ahead and lock my door
the program is still interrupted so what
I need to do
is cycle start it back up to get it
started again so cycle start
we'll see that the tool and the coolant
started back up
and I'm feeling pretty comfortable with
this program so I'm actually going to
let this run
at 100 feed and a hundred percent uh so
rapid and linear here so we'll turn this
all the way up to 100 percent
and then we'll also turn this all the
way up to 100 percent
normally you'd want to probably single
block this out or go through a more you
know step-by-step process checking every
single tool path I know that this
program is good I'm not going to sit
here with you for the next 20 minutes
and single block this out with you but
this is pretty much how I would
typically go through a second operation
set up and run and I would just let this
run out and at this point I'm pretty
confident that I can run production on
this part and I would just keep going
back and forth with my work offset as I
measure each component to ensure that
I'm with intolerance so I think that
pretty much covers it for this video the
finished result is going to be the 98432
part
and it would look like this on the
blueprint
[Music]
so I'm going to be making a hand for
more or sorry a handful more of these
but I appreciate you sticking around and
watching this video hopefully this was
helpful uh and I'll go ahead and catch
you in the next one thanks
bye